We got an amazing crowd here this evening and--
(audience cheers)
Oh yeah.
They're happy about--
Oh, you got that right!
I love this crowd, especially the ladies, huh?
Sir, excuse me, who are you?
What's going on?
I'm Lou Grebinski, a New York City construction worker.
Okay, well, Lou, we don't really need you
out here harassing the women in our audience.
Hey, I take offense to that, Conan!
These days, every construction worker
in New York City is required to go through hours
of sensitivity training and psychotherapy.
We're all totally woke now.
(audience laughs)
Okay, let me get this straight, you're saying you're woke.
So woke!
I mean, I still shout at the ladies.
Check this out.
Hey you!
Hey you, yeah, you!
(audience laughs)
You are not an object.
You are a human being
and I respect your right not to be ogled.
Wow, I gotta say, that's--
(audience cheers)
Very nice!
I'm telling you, I am so woke!
Okay.
Oh, hello there.
(chuckles)
Hello.
Yeah, you.
That's right.
I'll tell you something.
You are not defined by your gender,
but by your own human agency, know what I'm talking about?
(audience laughs)
I value you and respect you as an equal!
Yeah!
Okay.
Huh, there you go!
That was terrific.
That was very good.
Yeah.
That's right.
And I'm telling you something, Conan, it is not easy.
Believe me, right below the surface, some things lurk.
That was creepy.
Yeah.
(audience laughs)
We don't need to go into that.
Oh man, look at her!
(chuckles)
Hey lady.
(audience laughs)
Oh yeah.
Let me tell you something.
I do not have access to your sexuality
just because I can see you with my eyes.
I respect your personal space, huh,
and I endeavor to narrow the gap between us created
by a ruling patriarchy that believes
you should have a lower salary and less rights.
(purrs)
(audience laughs)
Woke!
All right, that's--
Totally woke!
Stop saying woke.
That was great though.
You shouldn't keep yelling woke, but I am proud of you
and let's move on.
Woke!
Okay, let's move on.
Hey, Conan, Conan.
Yeah, Lou?
I just wanted to add one more thing.
What's that?
You got a real pretty mouth.
(audience laughs)
I think we should go, we're gonna move along now.
You're a tall drink of water, O'Brien!
I wanna start at your toes
and take a week to get to your pretty little nose!
All right, that's enough!
Lou Grebinski, everybody!
Thank you.
All right.
Nice to have you.
(audience applauds)
Woke!